in der klimakrise läuft uns die zeit
davon außenpolitische krisen spitzen
sich zu bei der digitalisierung hinkt
deutschland hinterher und wegen corona
wächst die schere zwischen arm und reich
aber wenn man sich einmal die programme
durchließen er gibt es mehr oder weniger
keine große partei die wirklich einen
fahrplan dafür hat nur versprechungen
nur versprechungen darauf haben wir als
generation kein boxen wir wollen taten
sehen merkel wird sich um all diese
probleme nicht mehr kümmern ich gebe nie
war meine stimme einer partei und auch
mein engagement einer partei hinter der
ich der und hinter deren inhalt sich der
im september wählen wir neu aber wenig
würde mir wirklich schwer gedanken
machen ob ich eine kleine partei meine
stimme gebe wenn ich jetzt in dieser
wahl realpolitisch verändern möchte wenn
wir am 26 september einen neuen
bundestag wählen dann ist die auswahl
riesig finde ich hier in sachsen anhalt
stehen 19 verschiedene parteien auf dem
wahlzettel deutschlandweit treten 47
verschiedene parteien an die meisten
davon dass im sogenannten kleinen
parteien und die werden vor allen dingen
von jungen leuten gewählt bei den
letzten landtagswahlen bekam die
sonstigen von den 18 bis 29 jährigen in
baden württemberg zusammen 13 prozent in
rheinland-pfalz 15 prozent und in
sachsen-anhalt sogar 22 prozent
damit bekam die sonstigen von den jungen
wählern zusammen so viele stimmen wie
sonst keine partei jetzt steht die
bundestagswahl an und ich frage mich
warum wählen junge menschen parteien
wollt die tierschutzpartei die fdp oder
die partei ist meine generation von den
großen den etablierten parteien so sehr
enttäuscht oder warum gibt man seine
stimme einer partei die wahrscheinlich
nicht in den bundestag einziehen wird
[Musik]
um das herauszufinden bin ich in
magdeburg mit luisa verabredet sie ist
22 jahre alt und kandidiert in sachsen
anhalt für die partei wollte
die partei kennt ihr vielleicht von der
europawahl 2009 10 damals schaffte sie
den sprung ins europaparlament volt gibt
es in mehreren europäischen ländern in
deutschland hat die partei 3000
mitglieder sie setzen sich für eine
tiefgreifende reform der eu ein die
eu-staaten sollen in allen bereichen der
politik enger zusammenarbeit
ich hatte also ich hab noch bedarf
erfahrungen in der schule wo wir eine
aufgabe bekommt haben zu sagen mit was
uns am meisten identifizieren können
dass unsere stadt also jetzt magdeburg
sachsen anhalt deutschland oder in
europa und da habe ich das erste mal
nachgedacht gemerkt gab es für mich ist
das europa ich viel mit europäisch und
weiß gar nicht genau warum
und es wird super wenig datenbank
gesprochen von den also in den
etablierten parteien klar die fast alle
mit europäischen pässen so also das
freut mich natürlich aber wirklich ein
veränderungswille dass man sagt ja so
gut aber wir müssen uns verbessern
das nicht nehmen und es wird nicht
gesprochen auch da vielleicht zu europa
speziell mit europa werben bei dieser
bundestagswahl tatsächlich wenige
parteien hier in diesem park in
magdeburg ist mir dazu bisher nur eins
der grünen aufgefallen war das für dich
jemals eine option sich auch bei den
grünen zu engagieren weil ich meine die
haben sie macht die wollten doch nur
noch nicht hat oder auf jeden fall nicht
hat gerade und da könntest du doch nicht
genauso für europa engagieren und
vielleicht sogar schneller erfolgreicher
sollen ja tatsächlich war das für mich
nie eine option also die etablierten
parteien zu den ich jetzt die grünen mit
seele weil die großen parteien waren für
mich nie attraktiv also da habe ich mir
nie die frage gestellt ob jetzt aktiv
ein friedrich habe ich das verfolgt und
ich finde auch vieles gut was die grünen
machen natürlich wir haben auch viele
überschneidungen punkte
und trotzdem war es nicht so dass ich
dachte ja dann ist sich jetzt voll gerne
mit dabei sein
aber warum ist ich sehe auch bei den
grünen das jetzt schon so
und einfach so viel abdecken müssen das
inhaltliche schwerpunkte die mir und
auch den anderen jetzt hilft mir dabei
sind verloren gehen kleine parteien
müssen wenig kompromisse machen sie
können konsequente vielleicht auch
radikale positionen vertreten ohne diese
tatsächlich umsetzen zu müssen das ist
ein vorteil findet jan philipp er
engagiert sich bei der fdp der
ökologisch demokratischen partei man hat
halt eben diesen hauptaspekt man
wirklich zu 100 prozent die werte
vertreten kann die man auch steht die
fdp steht in der klimapolitik für die
einhaltung des 1,5 grad ziels ein
zentraler grundsatz ist außerdem die
achtung vor dem leben daraus ergibt sich
zum beispiel eine skepsis gegenüber
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen und aktiver
sterbehilfe
bundesweit hat die partei mehr als 8000
mitglieder zwei drittel davon leben in
bayern dort ist die edv besonders aktiv
jan-philipp engagiert sich im süden von
bayern sein erstes ziel ist es mit der
fdp in den bundestag zu kommen aber auch
wenn das nicht klappt sieht er einen
sinn in seinem engagement mit jeder
stimme die an uns geht die grünen spüren
es gibt da konkurrenz also die grünen
die sind wie eine situation dass sie von
allen anderen parteien eher von ihren
lehrern idealen weg gezogen werden und
wir sind die partei die spüren hey da
gibt es noch eine andere ökologische
konsequente partei sind noch
konsequenter wie wir und jede stimme für
die fdp da merkten die grünen aber krass
also wenn wir noch weiter von unseren
idealen weg gehen dann werden die noch
mehr stimmen bekommen also wir ziehen
die grünen quasi immer mehr in richtung
ihrer eigenen haltung die sorgen dafür
dass die grünen konsequent bleiben und
ich glaube das ist genau das
entscheidende mittel gerade auch für
einen konsequenten klimaschutz
zurück zu wollt auch mit luisa spreche
ich darüber inwiefern ist denn sinn
macht eine kleine partei zu unterstützen
also das argument kommt ja auch das ist
eine verschenkte stimme ist weil wir
nicht erreichen können aber ich glaube
nicht wirklich an verschenkt die stimmen
je mehr ich mich damit beschäftige weil
ich gebe meine stimme einer partei und
auch mein engagement einer partei hinter
der ich stehe und hinter deren inhalt
wenn ich dir als alle vier jahre wieder
an den kompromiss zu wählen mit dem hier
eigentlich nicht zufrieden sind uns mehr
gas passiert das passiert überhaupt
nicht und dann muss man auch sagen dass
jede wahl kriegten land und setzt neue
inhalte der neue impulse tatsächlich
haben beide parteien schon zählbare
erfolge zu verbuchen nicht nur wollt
auch die fdp ist im eu parlament
vertreten
gold setzt außerdem in einigen
stadträten in köln bonn und münster
regieren sie sogar mit die fdp stellt
zum beispiel in bayern einige
bürgermeister ich habe den eindruck die
isar und jan-philipp geht es tatsächlich
um die sache sie sind sehr idealistisch
das wort oder et deutlich weniger macht
haben als große parteien scheint sie
wenig zu stören weil sie das gefühl
haben sich kompromisslos für eine sache
einsetzen
aber worauf wir alle generationen keinen
bock haben ist in der partei zu gehen
und zu sagen ich warte jetzt mal fünf
jahre bis ich mal eine position bin wo
ich etwas verändern kann warte ich noch
weitere fünf jahre bis ich dann auch
irgendwie an die position gewählt werde
sondern wir sind eine generation die
jetzt was verändern will und es ist
wesentlich einfacher im jetzt was zu
verändern wenn man auf die straße geht
wenn man sich endlich aus engagiert oder
wenn man sich bei kleinen parteien
engagiert und das ist glaube ich so die
motivation jetzt was zu verändern und
nicht ewig zu warten nicht ewig
taktische spielchen mitspielen zu wollen
darauf haben wir glaube ich keinen bock
also ich zumindest darauf keinen bock es
gibt auch gute gründe ganz bewusst keine
kleine partei zu wählen dazu später mehr
schauen wir erstmal auf die große
auswahl an parteien diese sieben kennt
ihr sie gelten als groß weil sie mit
einer fraktion im bundestag vertreten
sind diese 40 sind es nicht sie sind die
kleinen parteien da ist alles mögliche
dabei zum beispiel radikale parteien wie
die npd eine rechtsextreme partei oder
die mlpd eine linksextremistische partei
viele kleine parteien sind
monothematisch wir setzen in ihrem
programm also vor allem ein thema zum
beispiel die tierschutzpartei oder die
partei für gesundheitsforschung manche
parteien sind bei dieser bundestagswahl
das erste mal dabei zum beispiel die
basis sie ging aus den protesten gegen
die staatlichen maßnahmen zur bekämpfung
der korona pandemie hervor die stimmen
die all diese parteien zusammen bekommen
werden am wahlabend möglicherweise unter
sonstige aufgeführt weil sie die
fünf-prozent-hürde nicht schaffen das
heißt sie bekommen weniger als fünf
prozent aller stimmen wenn sie auch kein
direktmandat erringen bekommen sie
keinen sitz im bundestag bei der
bundestagswahl 2017 kam die kleinen
parteien zusammen auf 5 prozent im
detail sei das ergebnis so aus
nicht interessiert warum vor allem junge
menschen kleine parteien wählen darüber
spreche ich mit professor uwe jun er ist
politikwissenschaftler und hat dazu
geforscht zwei gründe sind für ihn
besonders entscheidend die jüngere wir
dann eben noch weniger partei gebunden
sind als ältere und jüngere wähler die
großen parteien cdu und spd noch stärker
so als altbacken wahrnehmen das ist eine
welt ihrer eltern und großeltern und
nicht über eigene zum teil also
zumindest ein teil der wählerschaft und
dass deswegen viel größere offenheit für
alle parteien da ist auch für diejenigen
die eben geringere chancen haben die
fünf prozent hürde zu meistern und dass
deswegen die größere bereitschaft auch
da ist diese zur em natürlich muss man
sagen dass kleinere parteien dürften
zweiter grund wer in den sozialen
netzwerken stärker präsent sind weil sie
eben nicht die traditionellen medien zur
verfügung haben und das ist ja auch eine
sind ja die kanäle die auch von den
jüngeren stärker beachtet werden und
deswegen finden die kleineren parteien
bei den jüngeren auch noch mal größere
offenheit waren
auch die traditionellen medien
zurückhalten würden sie denn sagen dass
auch in zukunft wird meine generation
wird diese wählerschaft eher kleine
parteien wählen und wird es dann
einfluss auf die parteienlandschaft
haben es schwer prognostizierbar das
sehen wir insgesamt dass die räder
schafft sich immer stärker von
situativen momenten kriegen lässt also
das was an themen an kandidaten an an
einfach an images aktuell kursiert das
beeinflusst die reeder sehr stark und
ich vermute dass das in zukunft auch
nicht abnehmen wird das heißt eben dass
diese situative sehr stark temporäre
element weiterhin wesentlich auf die
wahlentscheidung bestimmen wird um von
daher sind ist es ganz ganz schwer
gerade bei den jüngeren wählern kaum
partei gebunden sind hier ernsthafte
prognosen abzugeben ich habe tatsächlich
schon eine kleine partei gewählt und
zwar bei der europawahl 2009 10 da gab
es keine fünf-prozent-hürde und deswegen
hatten auch kleine parteien eine gute
chance ins parlament einzuziehen aber
lohnt es sich auch bei dieser
bundestagswahl darüber will ich mit
jungen leuten in der mainzer innenstadt
sprechen
die partei die partei
warum so ein bisschen weil ich von der
größeren parteien nicht fühle mich nicht
gut vertreten die tierschutzpartei ich
mal gewählt ist das klar
weil ich das vertrauen zu den großen
parteien
also wenn ich eine kleine partei wählen
würde dann schon eher deswegen also halt
weil mich die inhalte dann überzeugen
würden oder ich das gefühl habe sie
steht er für das 1
für das gehalt medien so genau aber
jetzt bei der jetzigen wahl weiß es noch
nicht wir durchleben gerade zeit in der
es diesen luxus mich die protestparteien
zu wählen
und vielleicht ein konservativer ansatz
aber ich finde gerade jetzt können wir
stabilität jünger und außenpolitisch
benzin verbrauchen weil die großen ich
um so oft enttäuscht haben dann denkt
man sich ok dann warum wenn es schief
gehen wir zeigen warum nicht eine
kleinere partei auf die chance geben
bald kosten haben oft genug schon zu
bekommen und dann sollte eine kleine
partei auch irgendwann die chance
bekommen sich zu beweisen bei den
piraten vielleicht noch mal einfach das
thema aber selbst wenn sie jetzt nicht
in regierungsverantwortung und auch
nicht liebe prozent hürde geschafft
haben glaube ich was wichtig dass es die
partei gab weil sie dadurch fokus
gesetzt haben und die anderen parteien
und auch nachziehen müssten also auch
eine partei die nicht in
regierungsverantwortung
kommt kann durchaus die politik
beeinflussen wie ist das bei euch habt
ihr schon mal eine kleine partei gewählt
warum oder kommt das für euch gar nicht
in frage schreibt das mal unten in die
kommentare die jungen werden also die 18
bis 29 jährigen machen bei dieser wahl
übrigens 14,4 prozent der
wahlberechtigten aus das ist im
vergleich zu den anderen altersgruppen
wenig die stimmen der jungen wählerinnen
für kleine parteien werden wohl keinen
so großen unterschied machen also lohnt
es sich wirklich eine kleine partei zu
wählen das habe ich professor jungen
gefragt aber auch jan schippmann vom
funkkanal die da oben und meine
perspektive ist das keine gute idee das
hat diverse gründe
aber der wichtigste grund ist glaube ich
dass man sich von der idee verabschieden
muss dass es eine partei gibt die einen
die 100 prozent der eigenen politischen
idee abbildet dass das passiert nicht
wenn man in der vierer wg wohnt dann
kann man sich auch nicht einigen ob
alles und wenn man 50.000 mitglieder hat
dann erst recht nicht da muss man
einfach priorisieren gucken wo die
eigenen ideen sich am meisten wieder
finden und sich dann in der bestehenden
partei engagieren die tatsächlich auch
chancen hat auf der politische
mitbestimmung damit möchte ich nicht in
abrede stellen deshalb gut leute sind
und gute position vertreten manchen
parteien aber im endeffekt wird das
wahrscheinlich keinen großen unterschied
machen das muss man halt immer sehen und
im zweifelsfalle stärkt man dann
vielleicht andere parteien mit dem mann
überhaupt nicht übereinstimmt wo wir nun
sieht das anders wir sind keine
verschenkten stimmen aus zweierlei
hinsicht nämlich erstens man macht ihr
ein politisches statement man gibt ein
gutes statement ab und man wird eben
nicht taktisch sondern entscheidet sich
für die partei die einem selbst am
meisten zusagt und das ist schon mal
nicht verschenkt und zum zweiten muss
man auch sagen dass eben jede partei die
ihn mindestens 0,5 prozent der
zweitstimmen auf sich vereint an der
staatlichen parteienfinanzierung
teilnimmt und von daher würde ich von
verschenkten stimmen nicht sprechen
sicherlich verschenkt in dem sinne dass
man nicht unmittelbar an der
regierungsbildung beteiligt ist dann mit
seiner stimme aber in vielerlei hinsicht
eben ist es nicht verschenkt ob ihr eine
der kleinen oder eine der großen
parteien welt bei dieser bundestagswahl
dass es ganz alleine euch überlassen
[Musik]